San Diego is going about to become the
second city in the country that is
banning dogs being sold from puppy mills
so you won't be able to go to your pet
store and get you know that special
breed that you really wanted and instead
you're going to have to save an animal's
life by going to a shelter and they're
resilient great animals out there my dog
is a rescue from Hurricane Katrina after
New Orleans and she is the love of my
own i just i love it 10 times more look
at that well she gave birth during the
hurricane nursed her puppies to help and
then came up here and she's she's a
great dog anyway I think this is just
fantastic i see no downside to this but
of course you know some people are gonna
scream about free market and you know if
people want to buy dogs they should be
allowed to do you guys see any badness
this it seems to me you're you're
actually saving two lives because of an
unnecessary birth you know just through
the puppy mill and you're saving a dog
that's most likely gonna be put down but
what are you saying are you saying we
have to wait for a hurricane to get our
shelter dogs oh you god forbid we had to
do that in a tornado dog could be Tony
yeah I feel like we need to change the
words puppy mill because that just
sounds adorable yes I want to go to the
puppy mill it's a wreckage outlet you
when you're driving it to Vegas or to
Palm Springs those outlets on the way in
the desert Oh what's up with a puppy
mill yeah the peppermill pop email or
something adore like you know like you
could roll around with a bunch of
puppies in the pop email via one of the
holes at like minigolf you know I mean
like you guys hole-in-one at the puppy
mill you know it just sounds too cute we
need to first y'all just stop that we
need to call it like that kitten torture
torture chamber the rabbit the mummy
right yes the puppy next to the north
fisting the puppy fisting factory it's
something awful where people go of
course we should get rid of a puppy
fisting pepper that's not even a
question that sounds like a punk band
from the 90 s doesn't it be misting
handing don't you steal that yes some of
the puppies are like it Oh Doberman well
you can't punish all of them because of
the females right that's not how we're
gonna that's number one let's stop using
that term yeah and then I think more
people will buy them from a rescue play
by let me just pick them up just pick
them up that's what I meant yeah I want
to donate but you want to do any money
because you're a good one no you know
I'm a dog person yeah uh you know that I
let my dog I I love I don't trust people
don't like dogs ever meet those people
yes who doesn't like but I don't like
cats do you trust me still yes I don't
trust yeah I can't shake ya douche
everything so the cat mill go for
America yeah exactly i do I um I wish my
dog could talk so why can't they talk
god damn it they know what you're saying
they're just like the Viet Cong yeah my
point is my point is yes it's a good
idea i just got my dog from up from a
shelter and yes why can't they can say
don't buy from you have to go to a
licensed breeder and make sure how will
we just go to the frickin pound there's
a hundred dogs there go there and get
your goddamn dog what do you think about
these people that'll say the free market
though if people want to buy it
mermermer burnt food what do I say about
them they're idiots they're just they
understand the problem and every problem
can't be solved by the free market yeah
right if it was if it could be we
wouldn't have health care problems if it
could be we wouldn't have lots of other
things but yes not every problem is
fixable by the free market yeah why are
purebred dogs such an awesome thing to
have I think it's just an elitist thing
because actually they're proven to not
even be as healthy they get joint
problems that older yeah all the best
yeah can you mix breathe yeah and you
know two dogs or get it on in an alley
somewhere in most West Covina that's
where the cute dogs that's where they're
making that next generations dog
Olympians yeah I dare that alley in West
Covina you know it's funny though
because actually those dogs have to
survive if you found a dog that you know
came out of a mill it's been hopefully
treat it's been coddled even if it's not
a good mill yeah it's been brought up in
you know it was just brought up and
raised just to be adopted another dog
had to survive and if a dog has to
survive it's gonna get some innate good
qualities i think my dog has like a
particular sweetness to humans because
they saved her and now she my dog is
afraid of hallways so it's different I
don't know what that is about he's
always afraid he's like ducks anything
but in a hallway so yeah I don't know
what happened but but he was really
skinny when we got him you can see it
every Spy you can see his vertebra and
his and ribs and I thought it was cute
I'm like all look he's skinny as a
skinny guy it's not human la your
Hollywood that's like have carbs for the
rest of the day thanks a lot my dog his
abs he would do really well in West
Hollywood yeah you fantastic all right
well okay so we're all agreed on this
easy segment there you go and if you
want to adopt a dog check out tales of
joy net our former guest Elayne Boosler
runs a really rescue situation and she
can connect you with some great